Générique
...
-Bonsoir à tous.
Faut-il aider à mourir
ceux qui le souhaitent ?
C'est une question vertigineuse,
infiniment complexe.
Si on répond oui,
immédiatement surgissent
tout un tas d'interrogations :
qui pour donner la mort ?
A qui ?
A seulement certains malades ?
A partir de quel âge ?
Comment éviter les dérives ?
L'aide au suicide et l'euthanasie
sont passibles de poursuites.
Faut-il légaliser ?
Nous vous proposons
un numéro spécial d'"Etat de santé"
pour tenter d'éclairer ce débat
avec nos invités, nos reportages.
Ce sera à chacun ensuite
de se faire son opinion,
comme d'ailleurs
doivent le faire les 185 membres
de la convention citoyenne
qui se sont réunis
depuis des semaines
à la demande d'Emmanuel Macron
et qui rendront leurs conclusions
début avril.
On verra ensuite
s'il y a une évolution de la loi.
On en parle avec nos invités.
Je suis très heureuse
de recevoir Sarah Dauchy.
-Bonsoir.
-Psychiatre à l'APHP,
présidente du Centre national
des soins palliatifs
et de la fin de vie,
vous dirigiez le département
des soins de support
à l'institut Gustave Roussy.
Bonsoir, Jonathan Denis,
vous êtes le président
de l'Association pour le droit
de mourir dans la dignité,
évidemment une association
très active
dans ce débat
et vous aviez accompagné,
il y a un peu plus
d'une dizaine d'années
précisément votre père
dans cette démarche.
Vous nous direz
si ça a été le réflexe
de votre engagement associatif.
Bonjour, ou bonsoir,
Matthias Savignac,
président de la mutuelle MGEN,
la MGEN qui a plusieurs services
de soins palliatifs
à travers le territoire.
Vous avez mené une consultation
auprès de tous vos membres
pour éclairer ce débat.
Finalement, il y a
une conclusion collective ?
Il y a un manifeste
qui vise à promouvoir
les soins palliatifs
et l'aide active à mourir.
-Soins palliatifs,
aide active à mourir,
des notions desquelles
on va parler.
Bonsoir, Marta Spranzi,
maîtresse de conférences
en histoire, philosophie et éthique
des sciences
à la faculté de médecine
de l'université
Versailles
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines.
Vous êtes aussi consultante
en éthique,
consultante d'éthique,
auprès de l'APHP.
Je vais vous demander,
parce que c'est vrai
qu'on réfléchit depuis des années,
grâce, notamment, à l'ADMD,
à ces questions
plus précisément
depuis plusieurs dizaines d'années
parce que, dans le fond,
notre rapport à la vie et à la mort
a considérablement changé
et n'a rien à voir
avec ce qu'il était
à la fin du 19e,
ne serait-ce qu'à ce moment-là.
-Tout à fait.
Je pense que la médecine
est prise un peu
à son propre piège aujourd'hui
parce qu'elle a
tellement de succès.
Elle a augmenté l'espérance de vie
depuis 1950 de 15 ans.
-On vit plus longtemps mais on vit
en souffrance plus longtemps.
-1/5e, au-dessus de 85 ans,
sont en perte d'autonomie
importante.
1/5e des personnes
au-dessus de 85 ans.
Et ça, c'est une première raison.
Une deuxième raison qui me paraît
plus liée à une question
à la fois psychologique et morale,
c'est que la précision du pronostic
et du diagnostic,
met un certain nombre de malades
dans une position de condamné à mort
dans laquelle ils n'ont plus
la possibilité de s'accrocher
à quelque petit espoir,
quel qu'il soit.
Et il y a une 3e chose peut-être,
c'est une frustration
créée justement par rapport
au succès de la médecine :
dans l'opinion commune,
la médecine peut guérir.
Mais certaines fois,
elle peut pas guérir.
Et donc il y a un contraste
très important
alors que quand la médecine
ne guérissait pas,
et c'était le cas
jusqu'à la
2e Guerre mondiale...
-Vous dites
que les progrès de la médecine
nous ont un peu piégés
dans ce rapport à la mort.
Enfin, il y a quand même
des certitudes collectives.
L'opinion,
lorsqu'on l'interroge,
et depuis longtemps,
depuis quelques années,
sur cette question,
elle est massivement favorable
à une évolution de la loi
qui permette plus de liberté.
Et nous sommes allés interroger
des Français
et massivement,
à une exception près,
ils sont favorables
à ce qu'on fasse évoluer la loi.
-L'euthanasie devrait être acceptée
pour qu'on puisse choisir
de quelle façon mourir.
-C'est leur liberté.
-On peut mourir sans souffrir.
-Sur des personnes qui sont déjà
bien avancées dans l'âge
qui sont dans des situations
de santé très dégradées,
c'est tout à fait légitime.
-Je ne suis pas d'accord
avec l'euthanasie
parce que notre vie appartient
à Dieu,
pas aux médecins,
pas à un médicament qui va tuer.
Non, non, non,
elle appartient à Dieu.
-La fin de vie, ça représente
pour certains des douleurs,
de la difficulté, de la solitude
et il n'y a aucune raison...
Il n'y a aucune raison d'endurer,
si on peut partir avant
et qu'on a les idées saines
et le cerveau bien fait,
si on a envie de partir,
on devrait pouvoir être accompagné.
-J'ai pu connaître des personnes
qui ont beaucoup souffert
à la fin de leur vie
et qui n'avaient pas
de possibilité réelle d'y mettre fin
alors qu'elles auraient aimé.
-De devoir aller en Suisse
ou en Belgique
pour un suicide assisté,
alors qu'en France,
on est quand même
la septième puissance mondiale...
Il y a un problème
et il faut faire quelque chose.
-Je trouve qu'il y a une sorte
d'inégalité devant la mort.
-Si elle arrive
et qu'on est grabataire,
qu'on n'a plus le sens de la vie,
qu'on est tout seul,
qu'on est nourri par sonde,
quel est l'intérêt de la vie ?
Enfin, quel est le sens
de la vie dans ce cas-là ?
En ce qui me concerne,
j'en ai rien à faire.
Je n'en veux pas, de cette mort-là.
Je veux déjà pas de l'EHPAD.
-"Je n'en veux pas,
de cette mort-là."
C'est représentatif
de ce que pensent
les gens en bonne santé.
Juste, docteur Dauchy,
question de définition :
dites-nous,
le suicide assisté, l'euthanasie,
quelle est la différence ?
-Dans les deux, l'intentionnalité
est que la mort survienne,
à la différence
d'autres dispositifs
comme la sédation profonde
et continue jusqu'au décès,
qui endort en soulageant
la souffrance.
Le suicide assisté,
la personne elle-même
s'administre le comprimé
ou la substance entraînant la mort,
alors que l'euthanasie,
une tierce personne le fait.
-La différence,
c'est qu'on est actif,
dans le suicide assisté,
mais on nous a donné
le matériel pour le faire.
L'euthanasie,
une tierce personne intervient.
-Sachant que la vraie question
est d'être actif soi-même
dans la prise de décision,
dans la demande de soins
dès le début
de la maladie et pas uniquement
en fin de vie.
-C'est vrai
que quand on pense à la fin de vie,
tout un chacun se dit :
"J'ai pas envie
de finir grabataire,
"de subir des souffrances
épouvantables.
"Je veux
"qu'on en finisse vite."
D'autant quand on nous a donné
un pronostic
de cancer, de maladie incurable.
Qu'est-ce que vous répondez,
vous qui accompagnez
les personnes en fin de vie ?
Qu'est-ce que vous dites à ceux qui,
bien portants,
se disent :
"Ben oui, faut en finir."
-Je pense
que ce qu'on leur dit
est d'abord une vérification
d'information sur la situation.
Avant tout le reste,
c'est peut-être surprenant
parce que le rôle d'un médecin
est d'abord de soigner,
mais il faut d'abord
savoir de quoi on parle :
dans les témoignages montrés,
aucune personne
ne mentionne l'existence
des droits actuels
de fin de vie et par ailleurs,
beaucoup renvoient,
ce qui est naturel,
à des expériences
souvent très douloureuses.
Le Centre national
fin de vie soins palliatifs
a fait en octobre un sondage
sur 1000 personnes française
âgées de plus de 18 ans,
pas pour évaluer
l'opinion des Français
par rapport à la loi
mais pour évaluer leur connaissance
de la loi actuelle : il n'y
a que 15 %
des personnes interrogées
qui savaient répondre
à 6 à 8 des questions
sur les 8 points majeurs
comme les directives anticipées,
la personne de confiance,
la sédation profonde
et le droit au refus de soins.
On a un déficit d'information
qui laisse la place et qui coexiste
avec les croyances,
les représentations,
les expériences.
Une des premières choses importantes
est d'arriver à savoir
ce que la personne qui va décider
sait de sa situation, de ses droits
et de sa situation médicale.
-C'est passionnant,
ce que vous dites,
parce qu'il y a une méconnaissance
du système actuel.
La loi Claeys-Leonetti
encadre la fin de vie.
Elle avait créé précisément
des nouveaux droits.
Elle remonte à 2016.
On va tout de suite
remédier, peut-être en partie,
à cette méconnaissance
en faisant le point
sur ce que dit la loi.
Regardez cette infographie
et on se retrouve juste après.
-En France, quatre lois régissent
principalement la fin de vie.
La loi Kouchner en 1999
garantit à chacun l'accès
aux soins palliatifs.
En 2002, elle va plus loin
en établissant la notion
de droit des malades et évoque
le droit d'avoir
une fin de vie digne.
En 2005, la loi Leonetti,
la toute première à traiter
spécifiquement de fin de vie,
introduit l'interdiction
de l'obstination déraisonnable
ou acharnement thérapeutique
et reconnaît le droit
d'arrêter tout traitement.
Elle instaure aussi la mise en place
des directives anticipées,
une déclaration faite par le patient
pour exprimer ce qu'il accepte
ou non pour sa fin de vie :
limiter ou arrêter les traitements,
être réanimé, être placé
sous respirateur artificiel
ou tout autre souhait.
Sous la forme d'un document
écrit, daté et signé,
elles peuvent être enregistrées
dans le dossier médical
ou simplement confiées au médecin
ou à des proches
qui les feront valoir
le moment venu.
En 2016, la loi Cleys-Leonetti
leur donne un rôle contraignant,
mais surtout,
elle accorde un nouveau droit :
la sédation profonde
et continue jusqu'au décès,
c'est-à-dire le droit d'être endormi
à la toute fin de vie,
sous certaines conditions.
Elle doit être décidée
via une procédure collégiale.
Le patient doit souffrir
de façon insupportable
et son décès doit être inévitable
et imminent.
La loi ne permet donc pas de donner
activement la mort aux patients,
ni de leur en donner les moyens.
-La loi est méconnue.
Ce qui l'est encore plus,
ce sont les directives anticipées.
On va en parler
mais d'abord,
sédation profonde,
en quoi ça diffère
de l'euthanasie ?
Vous, docteur Dauchy,
vous diriez que c'est différent ?
-C'est différent
parce que l'intentionnalité
n'est pas la même.
-L'intentionnalité de qui ?
-L'intentionnalité du médecin,
supposé répondre
à l'intentionnalité du patient.
Et la sédation profonde
et continue jusqu'au décès
peut se faire
soit parce qu'un patient décide
que ses souffrances
sont intolérables et réfractaires,
sans le prouver, en le disant,
donc c'est sa volonté,
son appréciation
et derrière une demande
d'être endormi jusqu'au décès
avec potentiellement
une ritualisation
parce que l'intérêt de la sédation,
c'est de pouvoir l'exercer
de manière programmée.
-La sédation profonde
est demandée par le patient
ou c'est le médecin qui décide,
à un certain stade
de l'évolution du malade
qu'à ce moment-là
il est éligible
à la sédation profonde ?
-Les 2 peuvent le demander.
Quand c'est le patient
qui le demande,
et le patient peut le demander
par ses directives anticipées,
par personne de confiance
ou seul.
Sinon, lorsque les médecins
considèrent que les traitements
relèvent
de l'obstination déraisonnable,
et qu'il y a décision collégiale,
on induit une sédation.
-La sédation profonde,
est-ce que finalement,
ce n'est pas la réponse
à l'aspiration
d'en finir
quand, voilà,
quand le corps n'en peut plus ?
-Ca peut être une réponse.
Dans l'article 4
de la loi Cleys-Leonetti,
il est dit que la sédation
peut abréger la vie.
C'est clairement écrit.
La sédation existait avant 2016.
Simplement la sédation de 2016,
qui est et continue jusqu'au décès,
a défini les souffrances
réfractaires
et le pronostic vital.
Ce pronostic vital à court terme,
il a fallu attendre 2018
pour que la Haute autorité de santé
le définisse.
Ca peut être une réponse,
mais ce n'est pas aujourd'hui
la seule réponse attendue.
Vous pouvez partir rapidement
d'une sédation.
Vous avez des sédations
qui durent des jours.
Le Conseil d'Etat appelle cela
les mourants
qui n'en finissent plus de mourir.
La question à poser
est une éventuelle ouverture
à la légalisation
de l'aide active à mourir.
-On va en parler.
Restons sur les soins palliatifs.
Leur objectif prioritaire,
c'est de soulager les personnes
en fin de vie
de leurs souffrances.
Je voudrais qu'on regarde
ce que font les soignants
à l'institut de la Verrière,
dans les Yvelines,
un institut qui dépend de la MGEN.
-Et les douleurs du ventre,
il y en a ?
-Il y en a plus.
-Il n'y a plus de douleurs.
Donc vous êtes bien confortable.
Bon, c'est bien ça.
-Oui.
-C'était quand même l'objectif.
-C'est l'objectif premier.
-Depuis votre arrivée.
-Je me suis endormi très tard.
-Il paraît !
-J'ai demandé qu'on me donne
quelque chose.
-Oui, un petit pschitt.
-Je sais pas ce que c'est.
-C'est un médicament
qui aide à se détendre.
-C'est ce qu'il faut.
-C'est ça.
-En pareil cas...
-Quand la mer est haute,
quand elle se retire,
la plage se découvre
et il y a des choses
qui réapparaissent.
Bon, c'est un peu ça.
Donc on peut parfois
reparler d'autre chose,
une fois les plaintes apaisées.
L'autre élément important,
c'est qu'on arrive
à s'intéresser aux patients
et qu'on parle d'autre chose
que de sa maladie.
Le médecin soigne aussi les patients
quand il donne pas forcément
de médicaments,
mais parce qu'il parle
et qu'il prend soin des gens.
-C'est extraordinairement touchant,
cette sollicitude.
C'est du soin, docteur Dauchy ?
-Pourquoi ne serait-ce pas du soin ?
Quelque chose qui répond
à une demande de soulagement
d'un patient, c'est du soin
et c'est de l'accompagnement.
Après,
par rapport aux soins palliatifs,
un point important :
lorsqu'on parle de soins palliatifs,
parle-t-on du soin
en tant que contenu du soin,
le traitement des symptômes
et l'anticipation de la fin de vie,
ou parle-t-on d'acteurs de soins
qui peuvent être
les unités spécialisées ?
Les soins palliatifs,
c'est tout un continuum
qui commence par des cas
non complexes,
par de la prise en charge,
du généraliste,
du médecin hospitalier
quand il est formé.
Quand on ne parle
de soins palliatifs
que pour parler des soins
très complexes, on parle de soins
auxquels tout le monde n'a pas accès
car indisponibles
ou parce qu'on n'en a pas besoin.
Tous les Français ont le droit
aux soins palliatifs
en termes de contenus de soins.
Tous les Français, heureusement,
n'auront pas forcément besoin
des soins palliatifs
réservés aux traitements
dans les unités de soins palliatifs.
C'est important
de comprendre la logique
de l'anticipation palliative.
C'est la capacité à discuter
le plus tôt possible avec le patient
de comment ça se passerait
si ça se passait pas bien.
Ca peut être des années avant
et ça va permettre
des soins palliatifs au bon moment.
-Intéressant.
Vous m'amenez sur le chemin
des directives anticipées,
à propos
d'anticipation.
J'en parle
avec Matthias Savignac.
C'était une avancée importante
de la loi.
Les directives anticipées,
c'est la capacité
que nous avons tous,
individuellement,
de mettre noir sur blanc
la façon dont nous voulons
être accompagnés ou pas
si on est malade, en fin de vie,
à un moment où on ne pourrait plus
avoir ce libre arbitre.
Vous les avez écrites,
vos directives anticipées ?
Les Français
ne savent pas que ça existe !
-Alors,
C'est du droit existant
qui est très peu mis en oeuvre.
14 % des Français ont rédigé
leurs directives anticipées
et je fais partie des 86 %
qui ne l'ont pas fait.
Par ailleurs, je porte le discours
de faire connaître ces dispositifs,
mais j'avoue
ne pas l'avoir fait
pour moi-même.
Après, une chose importante,
c'est que les directives anticipées
ne sont pas les dernières volontés.
Elles fixent
ce qu'un patient peut demander
ou ne pas vouloir dans le cadre
de questions préétablies,
prédéfinies :
le respirateur artificiel,
la réanimation.
Ca marche dans le cas où la personne
qui prend en charge un patient
connaît les directives anticipées
mais dans des situations d'urgence,
il y a souvent incapacité
à accéder à l'information.
Mais au-delà de ça...
-Il ne s'agit pas
d'écrire seul "Je voudrais
bénéficier de l'aide active à mourir
"si besoin était."
C'est beaucoup plus précis que ça.
Et alors,
on va sur un site, j'imagine,
si on fait
des directives anticipées,
on peut trouver
les questions très facilement ?
Seuls 14 % des Français
l'ont fait.
C'est dommage.
Comment faire en sorte
qu'ils s'approprient cette liberté ?
-Il faut faire des campagnes
de communication.
Matthias parlait du fichier,
le fichier national.
Comment prendre connaissance
des directives anticipées ?
Dans la loi de 2016,
il y a un article qui dit
qu'il faut créer ce fichier national
des directives anticipées.
L'ADMD le gère gracieusement.
Notre association.
Les généralistes
ont un travail à faire
sur ces directives.
Vous les faites pas
sur un coin de table.
C'est une discussion
à avoir avec les proches,
à avoir avec des soignants.
C'est compliqué de se projeter.
Je les ai rédigées,
mais il faut se projeter.
Il faut créer ce fichier
pour que les soignants
puissent en avoir connaissance
et désigner
une personne de confiance.
-Malgré cette loi,
qui a quand même eu des avancées,
les soins palliatifs...
On verra que malheureusement,
on n'en dispose pas partout
en France.
Mais malgré cela,
le député LREM Jean-Louis Touraine,
auteur d'une proposition de loi
pour faire évoluer précisément
le statu quo,
a eu cette formule
qui est souvent reprise.
Vous partagez, d'ailleurs,
ce constat de Jean-Louis Touraine,
Matthias Savignac ?
-C'est une formule forte,
mais qui a le mérite
de souligner le fait
qu'il y a des carences
dans notre capacité
à prendre en charge
le grand âge en général,
et la fin de vie particulièrement.
Evidemment, le fait qu'il y ait
un manque important d'accès
pour les Françaises
et les Français
aux soins palliatifs
peut laisser penser
qu'il y a une inégalité
de prise en charge et de traitement
face à la mort ou, en tout cas,
la perspective de mourir,
que le fait
de ne pas pouvoir accéder
à ces dispositifs,
peut faire que parfois,
on ne meurt pas dans des conditions
de soulagement de la douleur
ou d'accompagnement
le plus optimum.
C'est une question globale.
La fin de vie ne se résume pas
qu'aux derniers instants de la vie.
Il y a aussi l'accompagnement.
On parlait des EHPAD
ou de la prise en charge
au long cours.
On doit repenser
la chaîne de prise en charge
et d'accompagnement,
pour respecter
la volonté de chacun.
-Je voudrais qu'on regarde
un nouvel extrait d'un film
qui a été consacré
aux soins palliatifs.
Quand on parle
des soins palliatifs,
il y a les patients,
qu'on a vus il y a peu,
mais aussi les soignants.
Les soignants
sont parfois réticents
à participer, à être actif
dans l'aide à mourir.
On le comprend.
Parfois, il y a les patients
qui trouvent le temps long,
même dans les soins palliatifs.
Même quand ils sont
très, très accompagnés,
ils trouvent
que ça ne va pas assez vite.
Regardez. Institut de la Verrière,
dans les Yvelines.
-La mort,
depuis que je me bats
contre le cancer,
elle est en moi.
Elle est ma compagne
de tous les jours,
de toutes les nuits.
C'est elle
qui m'a apprivoisée.
Elle m'a dit :
"Je ne suis pas si terrifiante
qu'ils veulent bien le dire."
Maintenant,
je veux me reposer,
mais je croyais quand même
que ça irait plus vite.
-Ca veut dire
qu'on vous bichonne.
-C'est ça.
-Je trouve
que c'est un peu long.
Bah... Le temps
qu'il faut pour mourir !
-Ce que ça montre là,
c'est que...
D'abord,
c'est assez extraordinaire.
Quand on voit les patients
qui bénéficient
des soins palliatifs,
on trouve ça fabuleux
de pouvoir en bénéficier,
mais même là, certains trouvent
la vie trop longue.
Donc, on se pose la question
de l'aide active à mourir.
Qu'est-ce qui vous frappe,
docteur Dauchy,
dans les soins palliatifs ?
-Je voudrais...
Je vais répondre
à votre question,
mais je voudrais répondre
sur un point important.
On a parlé
de déficit d'information.
Le CNSPFV est un organisme
sur financement public
qui a été précisément créé
en 2016
pour favoriser l'information
des citoyens,
donc pas que des soignants,
mais des patients, proches
et citoyens non malades,
et l'appropriation des lois.
Il y a, effectivement,
un lieu prévu pour cela.
Par ailleurs,
la majeure partie des Français
ne connaissent pas
les directives anticipées,
mais dans le sondage évoqué avant,
on leur demandait
où ils souhaitaient
confier leurs préférences
sur leur fin de vie.
Il y en a environ 10 %
qui parlent de les confier
via une fiche sécurisée.
C'est un point.
Pardon
pour ce pas en arrière.
C'est important, là encore...
Je reviens sur votre question.
Les soins palliatifs,
c'est avant tout essayer
de s'ancrer
sur la volonté du patient.
Les soins palliatifs,
c'est forcément
un système de soins
qui doit largement intégrer
ce recueil des volontés
et des attentes,
ce qui veut dire du temps,
du contact avec la famille,
du travail.
-Il y a du boulot.
Vous parlez
de l'appropriation par les Français.
Les Français,
quand on leur pose la question,
ils sont favorables
de façon très massive, on le sait,
à ce qu'on fasse évoluer
la loi.
Un sondage a été fait
par l'IFOP.
Ils sont pour un changement
à 92 %.
92 % !
Quand on pose
la question dans la rue
aux Français,
avec des méthodes de sondage,
de façon scientifique,
ils sont favorables
à l'aide active à mourir
en situation de maladie
grave et incurable.
Qu'est-ce que ça recouvre,
madame Spranzi,
ce chiffre ?
Est-ce que ça veut dire
que nous sommes collectivement prêts
à une légalisation
de l'aide active à mourir ?
-Oui, je pense que oui.
La réponse est oui,
mais en général,
ça se voit aussi
dans le monde,
c'est-à-dire
que ce n'est pas un hasard.
A un moment donné,
des mouvements sociétaux émergent,
des besoins émergent,
et on les voit émerger en ce moment.
Je ne suis pas politiste.
C'est ma première question.
Je voudrais rebondir un peu
sur ce qui a été dit
et sur votre question précédente,
sur les soins palliatifs.
Un des problèmes actuels,
c'est de voir toujours
une opposition
entre les soins palliatifs
et une aide à mourir.
Ca, c'est dommageable,
car on a l'impression
qu'il y a une lutte.
Tout le monde
ne va pas vouloir l'euthanasie.
C'est une autre façon de mourir.
Je reviens au problème
de l'anticipation,
même pour des gens
qui sont en soins palliatifs
et qui trouvent
le temps long.
C'est surtout
cette temporalité,
car au fond, l'euthanasie,
c'est une façon d'anticiper,
d'abréger,
alors que dans l'autre sens,
les soins palliatifs...
Les soins palliatifs,
à mon sens, de façon regrettable,
c'est l'idée qu'il existe
un temps naturel de la mort
et que ce temps doit
être respecté
par une petite ration.
Donc, on dit au patient :
"On ne sait pas. On ne sait pas.
Ca va arriver."
Ce refus de moduler
le temps de la mort,
l'euthanasie le fait,
d'une certaine façon,
mais ce que fait aussi
la sédation
profonde et continue,
surtout si elle est appliquée
plus tard.
C'est dommageable,
parce que ça crée un besoin,
comme on l'a dit,
de cette modulation,
d'autant plus que la médecine
ne fait que ça, en fait.
-Alors, la question
qu'on se pose aujourd'hui ici,
collectivement, c'est :
est-ce qu'une bonne loi
est une loi qui est contournée ?
Matthias Savignac ?
Cette loi est contournée,
car de plus en plus de Français
vont ailleurs,
en Belgique notamment,
en Suisse,
pour trouver
les moyens de se donner la mort.
-Elle est contournée,
et depuis qu'on a commencé
à prendre attache
auprès de nos adhérents,
nos parties prenantes,
nos militants,
on a reçu beaucoup de courriers,
d'adhérents qui nous témoignent
de leur situation.
Notamment, j'ai en tête
une adhérente en Polynésie
qui nous a écrit pour dire
qu'elle passait
par la France
pour aller en Belgique.
Elle a fait 12 000 kilomètres
pour mourir loin de chez elle,
atteinte de la maladie de Charcot.
Sur place,
elle est hospitalisée à domicile
avec les soins, les accompagnements,
les psychologues
qui lui permettaient
de soulager ses souffrances,
mais elle ne voulait plus vivre
dans cette situation.
Je trouve singulier
de devoir faire 12 000 kilomètres,
d'être loin des siens,
pour aller...
Pour trouver une réponse.
-C'est un exemple frappant.
Pourtant, en faisant moins
de kilomètres,
de plus en plus de Français
vont en Belgique.
Vous le savez, monsieur Denis.
Nous avons suivi
le fils d'une femme
qui a choisi
d'aller en Belgique
pour se donner la mort
après avoir été diagnostiqué
d'une maladie grave.
On regarde. Reportage.
-Un sourire
jusqu'à la dernière seconde.
C'est l'image
que Nicolas gardera de sa mère,
euthanasiée l'année dernière
en Belgique.
-Elle sait qu'elle va partir
dans quelques minutes.
Elle a cette sérénité,
elle sait qu'elle y est arrivée,
parce que vraiment, son but,
c'était de partir comme ça.
Partir heureuse,
partir en pleine possession
de son cerveau, de son âme.
-Vouki était une femme forte,
comme en témoignent
ces albums jaunis.
Emigrée du Monténégro,
ingénieure
dans les télécommunications,
une femme brillante
qui choisit de décider de sa mort
lorsqu'un jour,
un cancer la condamne.
-Ca a toujours été
une évidence pour elle.
Moi, évidemment,
j'étais pas étonné de voir
qu'elle refusait
de devenir un légume.
Elle ne voulait pas perdre
son autonomie,
ni sa personnalité
et son âme, en quelque sorte.
-Comme Vouki,
les Français
sont de plus en plus nombreux
à aller mourir à l'étranger,
où l'euthanasie est légale.
A la frontière belge,
une bénévole française se dévoue
depuis 30 ans pour aider
les patients à s'y repérer.
Touches d'un clavier de téléphone
-Allô ?
-Comme tous les jours,
Claudette reçoit
de nombreux appels à l'aide.
*-On est à deux doigts
de devoir passer au tube
et tout ça...
-Oui, oui. Je comprends.
*-Lui, il m'a dit :
"C'est négatif."
-Il peut aller passer
une consultation...
Quand je dis une consultation,
c'est deux consultations,
à Bruxelles,
et après, son dossier
est ouvert en Belgique.
-Claudette fait
d'abord un premier tri.
Puis, lorsqu'elle juge
que les patients rentrent
dans le cadre légal,
elle les oriente vers un médecin
belge qui accepte de les aider.
Avec le temps,
Claudette est un peu devenue
sa secrétaire médicale.
-Bonjour, Yves.
-Le docteur de Locht
est un habitué des euthanasies
de Français.
Il n'existe
aucune donnée officielle,
mais les médecins belges remarquent
une augmentation des demandes.
*-Il n'y a plus qu'un seul hôpital
qui accepte des étrangers.
-Des étrangers, oui.
*-On n'en peut plus.
Ce mois-ci,
j'ai fait une euthanasie
par semaine.
Pour moi, c'est trop.
Au départ, avec Claudette,
on avait dit une par mois.
Je me vois mal,
comme la loi Claeys-Leonetti
le dit, dire à un patient :
"Vous n'avez pas encore
assez souffert.
"Revenez l'année prochaine."
Le patient, quand il sait
que son dossier est ouvert
et qu'il pourra,
peut-être un jour,
bénéficier d'une euthanasie,
il se sent beaucoup mieux
quand il quitte mon bureau.
Il y en a, parfois,
qui ont arrêté leur traitement
et qui le reprennent.
-Le docteur de Locht
prendra sa retraite prochainement.
Pour continuer à soulager
les patients,
Claudette espère
que la loi française évolue,
qui pourrait s'inspirer
des dispositions belges.
-Voilà l'extrait d'un reportage
d'Alexia Léperon
pour "Etat de santé".
Vous réagirez, docteur Dauchy,
mais d'abord,
Matthias Savignac,
ça vous inspire quoi ?
-La vidéo m'inspire
quelque chose qui me semble aussi
assez intéressant.
Il est éminemment important
de s'intéresser
à la volonté des patients,
dans ce qu'ils souhaitent ou pas,
s'intéresser à ceux qui partent.
Le début de la vidéo mentionne aussi
ceux qui restent.
Finalement,
pouvoir prévoir sa fin de vie,
comme c'est le cas
avec l'euthanasie,
permet à ceux qui restent
de dire au revoir à leurs proches
et d'en faire
un moment de vie.
C'est important,
pour faire le deuil
et garder ce lien.
-Je propose à Jonathan Denis
de nous raconter l'histoire
qu'il a vécu avec son père.
-C'est une histoire
similaire à celle racontée.
Mon père avait
un cancer généralisé
et il était parti du principe
que quand les souffrances
seraient insupportables,
il fallait que je l'accompagne
jusqu'au bout.
"Jusqu'au bout", pour lui,
c'était prendre un médicament
lui permettant de partir.
Ce médicament
ne l'a pas aidé à partir.
Il y a des modèles
à questionner,
sur l'aide active à mourir,
comme le modèle de l'Oregon.
-L'Oregon aux Etats-Unis,
où la personne
éligible peut aller chercher
un médicament.
A elle de le prendre
ou pas, d'ailleurs.
C'est intéressant,
car certains ne le font pas.
-Plus de la moitié
le fait seul,
avec des conséquences
souvent terribles.
Mon père l'a pris seul
et a été transporté à l'hôpital.
Il a fallu connaître le "bon"
chef de service,
qui connaissait mon père,
qui avait compris la demande
de mon père
et qui l'a accompagné
jusqu'au bout.
C'était une euthanasie clandestine.
Aujourd'hui, des euthanasies
clandestines se font chez nous.
Des Français paient
pour aller en Suisse,
vont légalement en Belgique...
-Une question triviale :
ça coûte cher ? Ca relève aussi
de l'égalité de soins.
-En Suisse, c'est 10 000 euros,
le coût d'un suicide assisté.
Il y a des Français
qui se font rembourser
en Belgique
les soins préparatoires
par la Sécu,
car ils sont transfrontaliers.
-On est un peu chez Ubu.
Pourquoi vous avez réagi ?
-Ce qui me fait réagir...
Je vais vite réagir
à certains points.
Le Centre national
est une structure publique,
donc non-militante.
Je ne rebondis pas là-dessus.
C'est un centre de ressources
et de référence,
et j'ai des informations à donner.
Lorsqu'on dit
que la loi Claeys-Leonetti
indique qu'il faut attendre
que les personnes souffrent assez
pour demander
à bénéficier de la sédation,
c'est inexact.
L'arrêt des soins
est demandable par un patient
les jugeant excessifs.
La loi Claeys-Leonetti prévoit
que si jamais
l'arrêt des traitements
peut entraîner le décès
avec des souffrances,
la sédation continue
doit être mise en place.
De plus, quand on dit
que les soins palliatifs
ne veulent pas
de changement de loi,
c'est la même erreur
d'interprétation,
si je peux me permettre.
C'est les soins palliatifs
en tant qu'acteur,
mais pas en termes
de contenu de soins.
Ce sont un contenu de soins,
ce ne sont pas des personnes.
Attention aux raccourcis.
Ca n'a pas de sens d'opposer
un contenu de soins
avec une volonté
de changer un texte.
Il y a des différences.
-Les soins palliatifs
ne disparaîtront pas.
Tout ça va évidemment coexister.
On aura
des choix supplémentaires.
On s'est intéressé
à ce que faisaient nos voisins.
On va en Belgique,
on va en Suisse,
on a des voisins
qui ont légiféré
plus tôt que nous.
Qui a fait quoi ?
Regardez cette infographie.
-Six, c'est le nombre de pays
parmi nos voisins européens
qui autorisent
l'aide active à mourir.
Les Pays-Bas et la Belgique
font figure de précurseurs.
Cela fait 20 ans que les médecins
y sont autorisés à donner la mort
aux patients qui le souhaitent.
Aux Pays-Bas,
un texte promulgué le 1er avril 2001
autorise l'euthanasie
et le suicide assisté aux personnes
qui sont capables de discernement,
qui expriment leur demande
de manière volontaire et réfléchie,
qui sont atteintes
d'une maladie incurable,
qui subissent une souffrance
physique ou psychique insupportable
et sans perspectives
d'amélioration,
et ce, s'il n'y a
aucune autre option réaliste.
Un médecin et un expert indépendant
doivent attester du respect
des critères d'éligibilité.
Les conditions d'accès
sont similaires en Belgique
et encadrées
par la loi du 28 mai 2002.
La demande doit être,
de plus, répétée par écrit
et lors d'entretiens
avec un médecin.
Le patient peut exprimer
ses volontés
dans une déclaration anticipée
ou en faire la demande expresse.
En 2014, la Belgique a élargi
l'accès à l'euthanasie
aux enfants
en capacité de discernement.
En Suisse,
la loi qui encadre
l'aide active à mourir
est encore plus ancienne.
Elle date de 1942,
mais n'autorise
que le suicide assisté
et non l'euthanasie.
A la fin du processus,
souvent accompagné
par une association,
c'est donc le patient
qui se donne la mort lui-même
en prenant un médicament.
En 2009,
le Luxembourg a rejoint
la liste des pays
qui autorisent l'euthanasie
et le suicide assisté
et a été suivi en 2021
par l'Espagne.
Dans les prochains mois,
le Portugal pourrait devenir
le cinquième pays européen
à légaliser l'euthanasie.
La loi sur la mort
médicalement assistée
a bien été adoptée au Parlement
le 9 décembre 2022,
mais elle se heurte à l'opposition
du président portugais.
-Alors, vers quel modèle
devrait-on aller,
Jonathan Denis ?
-On serait capables de faire
un modèle 100 % français.
En Belgique,
il y a trois lois :
soins palliatifs,
droits des patients
et dépénalisation de l'euthanasie.
Il y a le modèle espagnol.
Il y a le modèle italien,
le suicide assisté.
Vous avez le modèle de l'Oregon,
qui, pour moi, ne serait pas
un modèle s'inscrivant
dans la promesse
de solidarité, d'autonomie
et de fraternité de notre pays.
La France saura faire un modèle.
Cette Convention citoyenne
nous fait réfléchir
sur ce qui peut exister
à l'étranger
et sur la façon
dont pourrait évoluer
la loi en France.
-Vous ne voyez aucune réserve...
Vous n'avez aucune critique à faire
au système belge, par exemple.
Certains estiment qu'une fois
qu'on a fait sa demande,
une fois qu'on entre
dans le processus,
eh bien,
on ne peut plus en sortir.
Il y a une espèce de pression
qui s'opère
sur l'individu demandeur,
qui fait qu'on a perdu
le libre choix
qu'on pensait exercer
par cette même démarche.
-C'est totalement faux.
C'est le patient qui décide
et c'est le médecin qui consent,
et jusqu'au bout,
à la dernière seconde...
-On peut arrêter ?
-Bien sûr.
-C'est très important.
-Vous avez des personnes en Belgique
qui ne vont pas au bout.
Ca rassure les patients,
de savoir que ça existe.
C'est pour ça que parfois,
ils ne vont pas au bout.
C'est ce qu'on appelle le phénomène
de la porte de sortie.
Ca rassure qu'in fine,
nos volontés soient respectées.
-Intéressant.
Le fait de savoir que ça existe
peut dissuader certains
qui auraient été tentés
de le faire
si ça n'avait pas existé.
Alors, pour qui ?
Pour qui
faut-il éventuellement légiférer ?
Pour quels malades,
madame Dauchy ?
-Le Comité consultatif
national d'éthique
a pointé certaines situations
dans lesquelles la loi actuelle
ne répondait pas
aux désirs des patients
et a mis en avant l'exemple
des maladies neurodégénératives.
Elle hésite.
C'est l'exemple
le plus habituellement mis en avant.
Juste un chiffre
par rapport à ça.
-Les malades atteints
de ces maladies
avant qu'ils ne soient plus à même
de demander.
-Oui,
si ce n'est que
lorsqu'ils ne sont plus à même
de demander,
ils dépendent, en général,
d'une suppléance vitale.
La loi française autorise
absolument tous les patients
à demander l'arrêt des traitements.
En Oregon, la proportion
des patients atteints
de sclérose latérale
amyotrophique
qui décèdent par recours
au suicide assisté
est de 5 %
de cette population,
ce qui est intéressant.
-Ca dit quoi,
cette statistique ?
-Ca dit que c'est
une proportion plus importante
que celle des autres maladies.
Moins de 1 %
pour les cancers.
Ca dit en même temps
que ce n'est pas forcément
parce que la loi existe
que c'est la seule solution
pour ces patients-là,
mais c'est une donnée
essentiellement factuelle.
-Matthias Savignac, pour qui ?
Pour qui ?
C'est une question très importante
si on fait évoluer
la loi.
Pour quels types de malades ?
Les jeunes
pourraient-ils exercer
ce droit ?
C'est une question
très sensible.
-Je sais pas vous répondre,
Elisabeth.
A titre personnel, je peux avoir
des convictions, des idées,
mais je trouve que
c'est le genre de question
auquel il faut apporter
une réponse collective.
Je trouve qu'à ce titre-là,
la Convention citoyenne,
un formidable exercice
de démocratie,
permet aussi d'éclairer
la manière dont les patients
vont prendre la décision.
Il y a des comités d'éthique,
des professionnels,
des médecins, qui peuvent
s'exprimer là-dessus,
mais ce n'est que collectivement
qu'on définira
les contours de cette loi
à la française.
-C'est, en fait,
extraordinairement compliqué.
On est toujours tenté
de répondre
pour ou contre l'euthanasie.
Quand on entre
dans la problématique,
c'est très complexe.
Vous, comment vous répondez
à cette question :
pour qui ?
Marta Spranzi hésite.
-Je dirais
que, comme l'a dit
madame Dauchy,
il faut prendre vraiment les cas
qui sont les plus évidents,
ceux qui qui sont
les plus criants,
ceux qui sont majoritaires
dans les pays
dans lesquels ça se fait.
C'est ces situations
de maladies neurologiques
avec un pronostic vital
engagé de façon certaine
et avec une diminution
des capacités
qui est très importante,
sans oublier les cancers,
qui sont la grande majorité...
C'est la grande majorité
des cas,
mais ce sont des cas
moins problématiques,
du fait que le décès
est prévisible.
Les cas les plus problématiques,
c'est les cas du polyhandicap.
-Pourquoi ?
-Parce que là,
il faut évaluer non seulement...
-Vous voulez dire "polyhandicap
sans pronostic vital engagé" ?
-Voilà, c'est ça.
Je pense...
-Quelqu'un qui veut,
en fait, en finir.
-C'est aussi...
La majorité des gens
qui le demandent aussi,
c'est pour des raisons
de dépendance,
mais comme le disent aussi...
J'ai lu
des témoignages suisses et belges.
Ils disent que c'est
les cas les plus complexes
à évaluer.
La souffrance,
c'est celle
du patient,
mais elle doit être approuvée
par le médecin.
Dans une loi probablement...
Mais moi,
je suis d'accord
avec ce qu'a dit...
-Monsieur Savignac.
-Oui.
Une loi doit être déterminée
démocratiquement.
Il n'y a pas que ça.
Elle va évoluer certainement.
Les lois
dans les autres pays
ont évolué.
Il s'agit pas de dire...
Ce n'est pas figé.
On n'a pas arrêté de faire évoluer
les lois sur l'IVG,
sur l'assistance médicale
à la procréation.
Il faut pas se figer là-dessus.
Il faut commencer par quelque chose
qui habitue aussi,
qui crée un nouvel écosystème
de la mort
pour voir
comment ce système
à la française
va se mettre en place
et va pouvoir évoluer.
-A ceux qui craindraient
qu'on enferme la France
dans un cadre,
il faut comprendre
que ça peut encore évoluer.
On n'a pas encore parlé
d'une chose
qui est évidente
dans ce débat.
On essaye,
dans la limite
du temps dont on dispose,
de ne rater
aucune problématique.
C'est évidemment celle
des soignants.
Soigner, c'est guérir.
C'est le serment d'Hippocrate.
Or, là, on engage
le soignant
dans une démarche très différente.
Evidemment,
il y a des réticences.
C'est une question
qu'on a posée
au médecin gériatre
Jacques Weber
dans un service
de soins palliatifs.
-Est-ce que toutes les demandes
doivent être suivies d'effet ?
Il y a des réflexions éthiques
à mener.
Après, vous dire, moi,
à titre personnel,
comment je me positionnerais
si la loi évoluait...
Je demanderais peut-être
un droit au retrait
pour avoir mon libre arbitre
dans la décision.
-Le droit au retrait,
docteure, c'est quoi ?
C'est invoquer
la clause de conscience
et dire : "Moi,
"je ne veux pas en être.
"Je ne veux pas faire
ce type de gestes
"à l'égard de mes patients" ?
-C'est laisser
au médecin
sa liberté aussi,
mais...
Ca pose la question sous-jacente.
Ca renvoie
à l'éternelle question sous-jacente
de la compréhension
de ce qui est en train de se passer,
de la compréhension de l'acte.
-Ca veut dire quoi, ça ?
-On parlait
de la sédation profonde
et du fait
qu'elle pouvait abréger le décès.
Clairement,
on n'a pas de chiffres
montrant que la sédation
abrège le décès.
En revanche,
la sédation étant associée
à un arrêt des traitements,
de l'hydratation
et de l'alimentation,
un patient sédaté
va mourir plus vite
qu'un patient
qu'on n'aura pas sédaté.
Je parle de cela
parce que devant une sédation
profonde et continue,
jusqu'au décès,
des médecins se demandent
s'ils n'abrègent pas la vie.
Donc,
la question sous-jacente
du droit de retrait,
de la clause de conscience,
comme celle de l'intégralité
des actes en soins palliatifs,
pose la question de savoir
avec quelle formation on le fait
et avec quelle capacité
à anticiper...
Quand je parlais d'anticipation,
c'est pas ça.
C'est anticiper au sens
d'être capable de reconnaître
que la médecine
ne guérira pas forcément.
C'est savoir très tôt dire
qu'on va peut-être pas y arriver.
-Ce sont des débats
extraordinairement passionnants.
La communauté médicale
est évidemment très concernée
par tout ça,
très bouleversée
sans doute aussi.
La clause de conscience,
c'est est une évidence ?
-Bien sûr,
c'est une évidence.
On peut pas parler de libre choix
et demander aux soignants
de faire quelque chose
qui n'est pas dans leurs valeurs,
ou même si ça l'est,
qu'ils ne veulent pas faire.
On a vu le témoignage
du Dr Yves de Locht,
en Belgique,
qui expliquait
la dureté de faire
ce geste d'euthanasie.
Donc, vous pouvez
être favorable
à une évolution de la loi,
à l'euthanasie, être soignant,
et ne pas souhaiter le faire.
Donc, la clause
de conscience,
c'est indéniablement
la clé de voûte
du projet de loi
pour respecter chacun
dans ses convictions.
-Nous y réfléchissons
depuis 40 minutes.
Les membres
de la Convention citoyenne,
ça fait des semaines
qu'ils planchent sur ce débat.
Ils sont donc 185.
Ils vous ont peut-être
entendue,
Mme Dauchy.
Vous avez peut-être
été entendue par les membres
de la Convention citoyenne.
Certains sont arrivés
avec des certitudes,
ils sortent avec des questions.
On va voir quelques-unes
de leurs réflexions
et on se retrouve juste après.
-Les citoyens vont se réunir
à raison de neuf séquences.
C'est plus de 24 jours
de travail.
Il y a des auditions,
une formation,
des outils qui sont proposés.
On pense toujours
que les citoyens ne sont pas
capables de faire
des choses,
mais quand on leur donne
l'accompagnement nécessaire,
la délibération collective
produit des choses formidables.
-Le 1er sujet,
c'est santé et société.
-On va aborder
la morale et l'éthique.
Que veut la société ?
Est-ce que oui ou non,
on veut telle pratique ?
Par exemple,
sur le recours à l'euthanasie,
est-ce que oui ou non ?
-On a tous des expériences
de fin de vie.
-Ayant une maladie évolutive,
j'ai peur qu'un jour,
je me retrouve dans un lit,
à plus savoir marcher
et qu'on doive
s'occuper de moi.
-L'audition des soignants,
où là, on a eu
une quasi unanimité
des soignants, donc médecins,
infirmières,
accompagnants,
contre l'euthanasie.
Ouais, ça, je peux le dire.
Moi, ça m'a bouleversé.
-Ca m'interpelle sur des choses
que j'avais pas imaginées.
Musique pesante
...
-Il y a des groupes
qui se sont positionnés
différemment ? Oui ?
-Après cette cession,
on se rend compte
que c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué que ça
et qu'il y a plein d'aspérités
à prendre en compte, plein de...
Chaque fin de vie est différente
et la question
est pas si simple que ça.
-Oui, c'est bien plus
compliqué que ça.
Effectivement, Matthias,
il faut rappeler
que certains pensent
que de cet exercice
démocratique
dont vous parliez va sortir une loi,
mais non.
Ce sont des avis de citoyens
qui vont éclairer
le législateur,
à commencer aussi
par l'Elysée,
par Emmanuel Macron,
qui l'a demandé.
La loi, elle viendra après.
C'est une forme d'éclairage.
-C'est une forme de délibération
qui permet de prendre
le pouls de la société
à travers des citoyennes
et des citoyens
qui, avec ce qu'ils sont,
leur singularité, ensemble,
se forgent un avis collectif
qui n'a pas valeur de loi
mais d'éclairage
pour celles et ceux
qui auront la responsabilité
de voter une loi
autour de l'aide active à mourir.
-C'est un bel exemple
parce qu'on est rendu
à beaucoup de modestie,
une fois
qu'on vous reçoit tous,
pour expliquer vos pratiques.
Mme Spranzi, qu'attendez-vous
de cette Convention citoyenne ?
-Alors moi,
je suis frappée par le fait que...
Le moment auquel ça a été fait
et le fait que...
On a parlé tout à l'heure,
on a l'impression
que quelque chose émerge
de nouveau dans la société,
et plutôt que de s'en tenir
à des sondages
qui dépendent de la façon
dont la question est posée,
eh bien,
on va consolider cette...
cette opinion,
cette opinion publique,
on peut dire,
d'une façon plus structurée,
avec des citoyens
représentatifs,
mais qui ont été formés.
Et donc, je pense qu'en fait,
c'est une...
Ca donne vraiment
une indication
beaucoup plus fiable
que ne le sont
les simples sondages
de où nous en sommes,
par rapport à la réflexion.
Je voulais rebondir
aussi sur les soignants,
sur le fait que...
Je voulais donner
une statistique au Québec,
où le pourcentage
de ces décès
par aide médicale à mourir
est le plus élevé,
presque 5 %.
-Combien ?
-Presque 5 %.
C'est le plus élevé,
par rapport
à la Belgique, à la...
-Attendez, 5 % de quoi ?
-De tous les décès.
-De tous les décès ?
-Oui.
Presque 5 %.
Mais je voulais juste
rassurer les soignants.
Il n'y a que 0,5 %
des soignants qui effectuent
le geste, donc on n'est pas
dans le cadre
d'une objection de conscience.
Une objection de conscience,
c'est :
on est censé le faire
et on se dégage.
C'est un acte dérogatoire.
Or, là,
c'est vraiment une volonté,
une liberté
des soignants
qui le désirent,
de le faire.
Donc c'est très rassurant
pour les soignants.
-J'imagine que les membres
de la Convention citoyenne
ont scruté tous les exemples,
pas seulement européens,
le québécois aussi,
qui a l'air intéressant.
Qu'attendez-vous
de la Convention
citoyenne, docteur ?
-Qu'il en ressorte
ce qui ressort d'un espace
de pensée et de réflexion
autour de quelque chose
qui fait aussi peur
que la fin de vie.
Et ce à quoi on assiste,
et le centre est présent
via sa directrice,
Giovanna Marsico,
au sein
de la Convention citoyenne,
et ce qu'elle décrit
est un exercice démocratique,
mais surtout
un formidable exercice
de mise en situation et en pensée
d'une fin de vie qui,
habituellement, fait si peur
qu'on arrive à un débat très binaire
qui est,
plutôt que de penser
à ce qui fait peur :
"je suis pour ou contre".
La vraie question,
c'est d'avoir une réflexion
plurielle,
le plus en amont possible,
pour, chacun,
forger sa fin de vie
en fonction de ses attentes
et ses valeurs.
-Jonathan Denis,
pour conclure,
vous n'avez jamais été si près ?
C'est votre sentiment ?
D'obtenir ce pour quoi
vous militez
depuis des années ?
-J'espère,
mais je me méfie.
Il y a déjà eu
des Conventions citoyennes,
il y a déjà eu
une proposition de loi
sur l'aide à mourir en France.
C'était il y a deux ans.
Et pour autant,
ils ne sont pas allés au bout.
Donc oui, on pourrait parler
d'alignement des planètes.
Mais il faut discuter.
-Vous êtes
raisonnablement optimiste.
-Oui.
Et si la loi est votée,
je me méfie de l'application.
-Oui, il y aura ensuite
la mise en oeuvre.
Vous avez raison.
Merci beaucoup,
Jonathan Denis,
madame Spranzi,
docteur Dauchy.
Merci, Matthias Savignac.
On espère
vous avoir éclairés,
ou en tout cas aidés
à forger cette opinion,
encore une fois délicate
à se faire
sur ce débat sur la fin de vie.
C'est la fin de ce numéro
d'"Etat de santé".
Bonne soirée à tous sur LCP.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA